(tango music)
- Usually when people
first see the manikin
they're kind of wondering, you know,
what does it do,
I mean what's the purpose of it?
It has a mouth, it has
teeth, it has soft gums,
it has a cheek.
You can tell we got the
same haircut as well.
My name is Philip Briales.
I am the Director of Sales
for Columbia Dentoform.
We supply dental manikins
to dental schools.
What we basically supply
is their first patient
for them to train on before they actually
move on to live patients.
The company started in 1917
so next year, Columbia
Dentoform will be 100 years old.
The models, the manikins
are all assembled by hand.
We sell well over a million teeth a year.
(snapping)
We make a variety of models.
We provide models that
put tartar on the teeth.
We make models that have
a variety of disease
under the gums, on the gums.
If they need to,
they could do a root canal
on the dog and cat as well.
We have models that have
absolutely no teeth at all
so they can learn how to
do a complete denture.
(clicking)
The reason why it actually looks this way,
we really didn't want to put
any gender in the manikin
and so this could be anybody.
The design of it is based
on what an average human
would look like as far as
the size of the head, the ears,
the mouth opening, the
softness of the gum tissue.
The only thing it doesn't simulate
is maybe the bad breath,
but other than that it's a great patient
because it just cooperates with you.
I've been with the company for 41 years.
I have no idea that I'd be working with
dental manikins at all or all these teeth.
My granddaughters think I
work for the tooth fairy
and so that really works out well
because if their parent forget
to put money under the pillow for a tooth,
they'll tell mom just talk to grandpa,
he knows the tooth fairy.